A KWIC index system accepts as input a sequence of text lines.
Each line is a sequences of words and each word is a sequence of characters.
You can think of the lines as containing titles, something like titles.
A line may be circularly shifted by removing its first word and
appending it to the end of the line.
Thus, a line consisting of four words will have four circular shifts,
including the original.
The idea being, that we can index into the list of
lines using each of the words that comprise the line.
The quick index system outputs a listing of all the circular shifts of all
the lines in alphabetical order of the key word used to shift the line.
The idea is that if you want to look up any of those titles,
you can use any of the words that comprise the title to find it